inside of this box is the 14 inch M2
MacBook Pro this is the specked out 14
inch MacBook Pro and as you guys may
know or have seen in some of my previous
videos I was so dead set on getting the
16 100 I was so dead set on getting the
16. so you might be wondering why are
you right now unboxing
the 14. well my friends
I want to start this off by saying I
have never had an Apple product have a
problem any type of issue even with like
the butterfly keyboard when people are
having problems with those I still love
the butterfly keyboard I'm just gonna
put that out there and also like I love
the touch bar I actually maybe kind of
miss it a little bit but all that being
said when I was unboxing my 16 inch I
was making an unboxing video I'm super
hyped so excited and as soon as I opened
it
here we go so
like likes more exciting because I know
this is mine this is my baby I've been
going to bed every single night
thinking should I have gotten the 14
inch MacBook Pro should I have gotten
the smaller one
oh my gosh I can't wait it's here it's
officially here
so good so so clean so fresh
um Okay so
this looks like something
this little piece of plastic is like
coming up
look right there
what oh
[Music]
I noticed that along the seam of where
the display would kind of Meet the
casing there's like a small little
defect and I was like this is weird like
I don't think that should be like that I
think
this may alter the entire course
because English is the main language
don't talk to me right now so I'm going
to return this one but now I think that
this has made my decision to get the
14-inch MacBook
like I think that's what I'm gonna do
long story short reach out to Apple
customer service they were incredible I
returned the computer basically got a
refund that same day I also ordered the
14 inch MacBook Pro just like right off
the Apple website like I didn't have any
special treatment it wasn't like Hey
we're sending you another one no I went
repurchased this from like apple.com and
it said that it was going to get here
three
it's supposed to be here actually like
next week so this came super fast and
I'm so so hyped to open it now from day
one when I ordered the end to 16 inch I
kept having like not regrets but
something kept telling me Justine I
think that you might want to try the 14
inch but I knew that my MacBook was
already arriving I didn't want to wait
any longer I've been going to bed every
single night
thinking should I have gotten the 14
inch MacBook Pro should I have gotten
the smaller one and then this random
little mishap happened and it's one of
those things where I strongly believe
that everything happens for a reason in
life and I'm actually really excited
about this 14 inch now I'm back to
traveling a lot and traveling with a
smaller device something that is lighter
because I also sometimes tend to travel
with a PC gaming laptop plus my iPad and
a Kindle I have a lot of gear inside of
a tiny small little backpack so anything
that I can do to save space I'm so here
for it and the thing that I love about
the 14 inch is the fact that while I'm
saving space I don't have to give up
quality or performance this also I'm I
know I'm supposed to be unboxing this
but I feel like I have so much to talk
to you guys about because I have a lot
of thoughts I had been using the 13 inch
M1 when that first came out and to go
from that 13 inch to the 16 inch was
such a huge jump I almost felt like oh I
love this screen real estate I can't go
back but the screen real estate on these
14s it really isn't that much smaller
and it is larger than 13. I'm having all
sorts of justifications here I am just
very excited about this I had used the
14 inch M1 in a lot of beta tests but I
never used it as my main device so here
it is the 14 inch the unboxing it's
happening now
[Music]
yes I did end up getting a space gray I
hope I did I ordered it so quick
I honestly don't even remember
yes you are space gray and beautiful and
look at this
size it really is incredible this is
gonna be perfect
this is the right decision it just feels
right
I could not be happier this came at the
perfect time because I started traveling
again a lot and being able to have this
much smaller profile computer on a plane
has made such a huge difference because
I unfortunately fly Spirit Airlines and
those freaking seats and their tray
table is so teeny tiny I should have
taken a video the last time I was on it
because I was so freaking cramped but
this was so small that it actually fit
right on the tray table I was able to
edit for about four and a half hours
pretty much and had no issues whatsoever
the thing that I have noticed I mean I
don't know how you couldn't notice it is
the battery life compared to the 16 inch
because that 16 inch battery life was
phenomenal now this one it's definitely
not as good so it is a noticeable
difference but it's something that I
have so willing to deal with I've been
carrying just like a little portable
battery charger and I'll use that to get
a little extra juice if I'm on the road
or if I'm on a plane but this has been a
freaking Game Changer I always wanted to
have like the biggest and best computers
and having like the largest displays and
recently I'm like that's actually I
don't really know this is so perfect for
me I'm able to use a smaller backpack I
can fit this inside of this other little
backpack that I have that is so tiny it
definitely potentially might rip the
zippers but I can fit it in there I
can't believe it this is just
I love it so much I can't even say
enough great things about it like it is
like I know I sometimes get a little
dramatic and say it's life-changing but
getting the 14 inch for me actually has
been life-changing I would love to see a
compilation of all of the things that
I've said that are life-changing the
whole thing I did notice I think this
might be a final cut specific issue that
I've been having a little bit of Final
Cut lag when I'm editing I'm like kind
of fingers crossed like hoping for an
update but for the most part like this
thing is it's so fast I have traveled
pretty much around the world at this
point with this laptop and it has not
disappointed whatsoever my biggest
concern getting it was I thought that
the screen real estate would be too
small because I was so used to editing
with a 16 inch and honestly I don't even
think I've noticed at all like I just
have this and my phone and I can
basically go and work and do anything
anywhere and I have the eight terabyte
version and with that I'm able to do
almost all of my work right here on the
device I don't even need to bring
external drives you even though I bring
them I don't have to use them I always
do make sure that if I'm working on a
project I have it backed up on external
just in case I lose my laptop or
something like that I just I'm always so
afraid of this getting taken because
it's like yes I would be very sad that I
would have to buy a new computer but to
be honest sometimes the files and the
video are more important than this
device itself so I do either make sure
they're backed up to the cloud or they
are on a hard drive somewhere or a solid
state drive most likely it's a solid
state I also like this has a small or
charging brick so that also has
decreased the footprint of the devices
that I have to travel with one of the
questions that a lot of people have is
do I need to upgrade to the M2 if I have
an M1 and I'm just going to be the first
to say no you do not if I wasn't Apple
obsessed I've just seen I would have
stayed with the M1 because that thing is
so freaking powerful honestly you don't
need to upgrade if you do still have an
Intel MacBook and you are looking to
upgrade then that's where I say it is
time my friends go to the M2 or if you
can find an M1 cheaper then honestly
that's also a great route to go as well
either way I think that you will be
super happy with this and I am so
looking forward to WWDC to see what is
in store for the next version of Mac OS
and with that my friends I will see you
in my next video if you haven't already
be sure to like comment and subscribe do
hit the Bell so you'll be notified when
I post new videos and I look forward to
seeing you in the next one bye